- Heya Doc, you seem like
an utterly logical person
and I'm sorry to even be
asking you this question,
since it might upset your viewer base
should you answer.
You've piqued my curiosity.
(upbeat music)
Before we start, I gotta say
whoa!
Cells at Work.
You guys absolutely
bombarded my comments section
requesting that I watch Cells at Work.
I'm so curious
what is it about the
show that you like 'cause
I haven't seen it.
Is it that it's anime and
you're huge anime fans?
Is it a unique way to talk about medicine
that you really enjoy?
Please just jump down
into my comments section
and let me know why you love Cells at Work
and I promise I will get to it.
I will review it.
Now.
Let's respond to some
comments (robotic sound).
Are you religious
and can you be a medical profession
also a devout Christian?
Wow, heavy question.
I grew up pretty much without religion.
Neither of my parents
are or were religious.
I don't really celebrate
any religious holidays.
I grew up in an area surrounded
by all sorts of religions
'cause I grew up in Brooklyn.
But I never saw myself
as a religious person.
Not for any bad reasons,
but just because it
wasn't part of my life.
That being said,
I think you could be a religious doctor,
as long as you're not
doing anyone any harm
with your own religion.
Practice whatever religion you want to.
I think that's the beauty of
living in the United States.
Does reading in bad lighting
have a negative effect on the eyes?
Mari, it does actually because
you actually have to constrict your eyes
and make the muscles of your
eyes work a little bit harder
to concentrate on what you're
reading in poor lighting
and that sort of fatigue
is not good on your eyes.
Something else I wanna throw in here.
Looking a lot at the
specific wavelength of light
that's in our phones and computers,
the blue wavelength of light,
can actually contribute to a condition
called macular degeneration.
We've seen some early research on this.
Nothing that completely
proves cause and effect
beyond a reasonable doubt,
but it's enough that I should tell viewers
if you can limit some of your exposure
to blue wavelength light,
you should probably do it.
When should a girl start
going to the OB/GYN?
That's actually a really good question.
Abby, what I wanna really
tell you about this
first and foremost,
is that you don't necessarily
have to see an OB/GYN.
You can see your family medicine doctor
because we're trained
in gynecology as well.
The time that I would
recommend that you go
is somewhere between the ages of 13 to 15.
If you start having sex
and you become sexually active
earlier in your life than 13 to 15,
which I don't recommend,
but it can happen,
you should go at that point.
And it doesn't mean that
you're gonna get any tests.
It doesn't even mean that the
doctor is gonna examine you.
It could just mean that
we can have a conversation
about things that you're doing,
maybe answer some questions
that you may have about your body.
Starting early can set a
really good routine for you
that you'll fall into
without really worrying
on whether or not you
need to see your doctor
or is it too late.
Thomas Sears.
I think you're left handed.
Maybe you're partially right, Thomas,
because when I play baseball,
when I play hockey,
when I try golf very poorly,
I will always was a lefty.
So stick sports, I am lefty,
but I wouldn't say I'm left handed
because I write, I eat,
and I brush my teeth
all with my right hand.
Sweetest thing.
What are your thoughts
and or medical opinion on hookah
and the dangers of it?
Sweetest thing,
I've never smoked.
I've never done drugs in my life.
My friends always
sort of poke fun at me
that I'm the person that
never tried these things,
but I did try hookah.
And in fact when I was growing up,
I had a hookah in my house
because it was something that
all my friends loved doing
and it was just something that was around.
I didn't really smoke it a lot.
I mean I took a pull here or there.
I don't recommend it.
In fact,
when you look at how long
most people smoke hookah,
meaning how long they
actually spend inhaling
and breathing the air back out,
it's a long time.
And you still have the harmful effects
of tobacco,
nicotine,
the carcinogens from the
burning of the tobacco
going into your lungs.
It's not benign water vapor.
It's not completely innocent
like a lot of people say.
You're actually burning the tobacco
and then that smoke goes
through the water and comes out.
I don't do it anymore at all
and I haven't done it in ages.
I don't know, probably like 10 years ago
was the last time I did
it. Hookah is not safe.
It's not something you should be doing.
If you want to be healthy and happy
and play sports and be successful,
just skip it.
Flitdek.
Hey Dr. Mike, do you
listen to your own heart
with your stethoscope
out of curiosity or boredom?
I wonder if I can get
the mic to hear this.
(metal vibrating sounds)
Nothing?
Well I tried letting you hear my heart.
Yeah, I've listened to it before.
I haven't done it in a
really long time because
whenever I have this on,
I'm working and I'm busy.
In medical school especially,
I really listened to my heart.
Wadadli Studios.
Love the content, Dr. Mike.
What advice would you give an artist
engaging in a long-term
relationship with a doctor?
Biggest piece of advice I'll give you is
be patient.
Becoming a doctor is a stressful,
tedious,
difficult, but ultimately
very rewarding experience.
So the more patient you could be
with the person that you're
in a relationship with,
the more open communication
you can have with that person,
the more successful your
relationship is gonna be.
I remember a lot of relationships ended
during medical school,
and that was something
my dad constantly told me
he noticed within his class as well.
If you're meant for each other,
you'll make it through it.
If not,
great, you learned
something about yourself
and so did your partner
and you can take that on
and find a successful
partner in the future.
Misophonia.
Hearing recurring sounds,
bells, song lyrics,
and especially kids
babbling, complaining, crying
drives me to pull out my hair.
Could you address this condition?
Anon, I've never heard of it.
Let me Google it right now actually.
Let me check this out.
A strong reaction to specific sounds.
It's rare.
Fewer than two hundred
thousand cases per year.
Usually self-diagnosable.
And it says people may
experience anger, anxiety.
They can even develop
a fear of loud sounds,
or depression.
I've never heard about this.
This is interesting, I'm learning myself.
This is why I love medicine.
We're always learning.
We're always trying to figure out
how to better serve our patients,
and that's why I fell
in love with the field.
Doing research,
being able to find
information very quickly,
and specifically accurate
quality information
is a hallmark of the new
modern-age family physician.
William Cooper.
Hey Dr. Mike, can you help me get home?
I would gladly help you out, brother,
but I don't know what
you're asking right now.
Do you know what he's asking?
I don't know what he's
asking. I don't know.
Please make a video of
you opening fan mail.
Kirina, I wanna do that.
I just opened my P.O. box.
I haven't checked it yet.
The address is actually
down below for the P.O. box
in all my videos in the description,
so if you wanna send me something fun,
please do and as soon
as I get enough stuff,
I'm gonna open it on one video
and we can talk about what I'm getting.
Just make sure if you're
sending something personal
and you don't want it to be in the video,
make that very clear so I
don't hurt your privacy.
Hey Dr. Mike.
Have you ever had a
patient that started out
with the idea that it could
be a physical diagnosis,
but ended up being a mental diagnosis?
P.S., love the channel.
Thanks Nick.
And thank you for this question
because something I've become
incredibly passionate about
is mind-body disorders.
And I know that sounds a little bit like
a fru-fru diagnosis.
It's not.
The mind and body are truly one.
Communication happens both ways.
So if you do something
that affects the body,
it also affects the mind.
If you get injured or like
stab yourself in the leg
or get stabbed in the leg,
your heart rate goes up.
If something is going on in your mind,
you're depressed, you're anxious,
your blood pressure also goes up.
The mistake modern medicine makes
is that
there is an assumption
that all medical issues
come down to a physical problem,
a physical root cause.
And that's not the case.
In doing research
and in reading quality
books on the subject,
what I've found is
there are a ton of medical conditions
that are actually caused by
the mind-body connection,
instead of just the physical cause.
That's why a big part of this
movement in modern medicine
is to seek out mindfulness,
because mindfulness doesn't just mean
being in touch with your breathing.
Yes, that could be part of it.
But also, it means being in touch
with your emotional side of things.
Because emotions have an
impact on your physical body.
That's been proven.
There are a lot of patients that come in
wanting a physical diagnosis
or believing they have
a physical diagnosis,
and then they walk out
with their problem gone,
with their
cause of the problem solved.
Not because I did
something physical to them
like a shot, injection, or therapy,
but just because we had
a very good conversation
and they learned something
about themselves.
From rummaging in the comments section,
or running around the streets,
I love answering your questions.
So please keep them coming.
Drop your questions
and comments down below.
Also very important,
don't forget to hit subscribe
and hit that notification bell.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
Dry mouth today.
I said subject sab-ject.
Anon anon.
Miso--
Misophonia.
(sneezing)
Anon.
Oh man these sneezes.
I'm allergic to something.
Anon.
(upbeat music)